I think that if I paint the narrative of
me wanting to buy the Jets for 30 years
when I buy the Jets
everybody's gonna freak the [ __ ] out
keeps me motivated no there's a real
dirty see Drago keep on you guys hear
like identify fighter jets right like
I'm on them for us
I need a video four years ago that sits
in the cloud and hopefully doesn't
disappear where I literally talk about I
actually this is the worst day of my
life
and it's the whole narrative of the day
I guess how upset I am because I love
the climb right and that's what I'm here
for
like that's why I'm even here about the
climb I love like talking about stuff of
PE I'm on the climb I love the process
am i creating such a heavy North Star
you know it's creating a game record you
know keep climbing without ever really
having to change it I feel like
resetting your North Star I'm a very big
shoot for the moving render the clouds
I feel like always having that door
start it is maybe a much more honorable
legacy driven onto the more because I'm
trying to go for this big thing and a
lot of things gonna happen over the next
40 years
so skimming an extra 50k as a salesman
isn't gonna help me you know because
that person might help me in 13 years
when they're XY and Z and so I think
it's a mechanism that I create for a
couple of reasons one the Jets
represented to me becoming an American
and then they don't wear weights like
the ultimate Kickstarter right like my
real plan is probably 75 and I feel like
get there I'm just gonna ask everybody
to help me and I feel like if I can
effect enough people with the narrative
everybody's gonna want to kick in there
five twenty mean cents